bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fra vigenti siamo
tornati sugli aerei stigma collection
erano rimasti ragazzi che avevamo fatto
escaping prison che era la prima dopo il
prologo di breaking the bank dove hanno
incarcerato questo valore di sting ben
per aver tentato di rubare in banca
miseramente fallito il tentativo durato
cinque minuti io sarei durato di più e
questo è tutto dire una volta che sono
fuggito dalla prigione arriviamo a
stealing diamond perché il nostro è
ristic ma proverò a fare un altro colpo
rubando un diamante stavolta speriamo
duri di più della banca delle sit com è
più grasso la sua destra prova per e
magico le zebre in tunisia un
archeologica al corso che sta la chiama
migliore cioè ristic burbank da rio e io
basterà in poi fai tu ma proprio come la
casa di carta con la moto e spoiler non
ne sposa caboto dentro la steering
daimon al monopattino va bene oddio ram
non ho schiacciato al bordeaux hanno
capito niente di quello che ho
schiacciato ma fa niente
ha funzionato raga nora che dobbiamo
provare a non morire mai ci trovo ci
provo ha funzionato subito fluff live
non solo alla sia mercole provare a non
essere mai peccato sarebbe stato
fighissimo scia ovest con scudo nei
bravo ha funzionato però no anzi è
giusto del premio premio basket si
mettesse cer mi sembra mm perfetta
non vedevo altre soluzioni sono in
quella dei bot
va bene le scrivo ma sono partito nato
fuori due stelle due stelle ciò aiuto
break e no capito mai perso tutto
dobbiamo fare un'altra roba facciamo
perché dal 5 al 50 c'è sempre sfiga york
locali certo mi sembra giusto che con
una pietra riesce a battere le pistole
degli agenti è il cecchino lancia gli
stick e grenade miss e mister takata
lavarda il melo sono sempre chiesto ma
le grazie di paul e sam tex ste robe che
penso esista un cielo ti rimarrà
appiccicata maestra sta roba bova
bacheca chi ne so io non so neanche
perché la colla nel tubetto non si
attacca quindi e cazzo di domanda va
bene è babbo devo scegliere sempre la
più strana perché quella più ovvia non
non ci azzecchi mai con la sceglie la
più strana da subito merda diamante beh
è stata una bella è stata un'ottima
scelta in realtà è ce l'ha fatta
però penso non l'ho perso spero ha fatto
la rai
in realtà guarda che non è andata così
si sta da schifo potevamo fare molto di
peggio conoscendomi quindi niente male
lo ritrae l'ho fatto perfetto ho fatto
un casino intanto c'è un sacco di bwin
questo miliardo
sul finale ce n'erano altri due fida
breve che non so cosa voglia di e
braidense ecco avevo fatto giusto
all'inizio ed è bene è giusto che sia
così prima fuori tipo lupin
ecco però rumena l'intel e porter è
sempre sbagliato secondo me non servirà
mai telecom mai però prevedere ogni
volta cosa succede ma giusto per
curiosità
ce l'ho fatta la frutta per una volta a
te le porte la funzionato incredibile la
pillola dell'invisibilità va bene questa
questa bellissima questa è veramente
[ __ ] howe è per noi non sa neanche il
narratore dove cacchio sono finito vabbé
penny ei beni ha funzionato per i
ultimamente sono abbastanza bravo wire
world rifle come facciano schiacciare
wormhole rifle scusami a e porta hanno
fatto una città porta va bene vorrei
leggerlo tutto ma il video anche se non
dura 10 minuti non fa niente andiamo
avanti lo stesso choir quello classico
la tom cruise va bene ecco user è il
martello non vedo
non debbo carlo infatti cioè mi sembra
giusto per chissa cosa faceva laser ma è
gigantesco come cacchio ti porta col
formaggio col formaggio te la porti non
vedo altre soluzioni se non mangiarti un
pezzo di formaggio e poi basta è finita
perché non puoi finita altro plank piede
non ci ho mai pensato nessuno una roba
anche solo per entrare in casa dal
balcone per far fare quello sta fumando
una sigaretta con un m4 di fianco va
bene o salto snapback rifle diamond
poteva vedere che odia lo schiaccio col
diamante che non è una brutta idea per
me è una frutteria bene
[Musica]
congrega me la sto cavando in questo
meglio di cui prima picco col piccone
questo anche un altro gioco adesso viene
in mente quale però effettivamente
stanno parlando di skype in the prison
questi che c'era una roba della porta
però ragazzi ha funzionato incredibile
era quella la cosa da fare plain tirato
una eroina plan in faccia incredibile ha
funzionato tutto questo raga pazzesco
del the sun tormento che retro nomi non
so cosa ci sia tunisia
let's go my boys alien global good ball
per non mettere poké ball perché siamo
la football 9 avere un giusto ma le 9
geniale finita bellissimo da edgar è che
non voglio non ha mandato giù a lui è il
proprio addio amy missing no il proprio
con quello che si paga tutto non mi
cresce al giorno promette stende diamond
ha calciato vini novembre non è uscito
nel desktop mushroom ecco qua
[Musica]
a noi gliene frega niente di proiettili
va bene allora bo allora e allora mi sa
che ho già vinto perché come facciamo a
era vivo il cucciolo l'intero dattilo va
bene il diamante l'ho preso però che è
successo al cannone la palla di cannone
hanno un cannone dentro come è possibile
tasti canio che il club ei nove ragazzi
bellissimo ma è geniale ma sta roba non
c'erano me la ricordo o nuclearizzato
tutto per evitare che quello rimanesse
gigante nella ge capital altro sono
passato dalla parte della difesa adesso
cos'è questo mi sembra un peso eccessivo
però va bene questi sono cos'è pacifique
rim non solo sta succedendo ma quella
fare sta che sto facendo il museo a meno
ma cagato sta facendo tutto l'opposto di
quello che doveva fare ma è finita ma
male cioè male bene ne se sono vivo ma
sono tornato normale che ormai è il
diamante pure ci hanno fatto un casino
inutile just play off line e frick
maqroll il prossimo ragazzi dovrebbe
essere
infiltrati english i ragazzi questa
questa è forse la mia preferita ci sarà
solo nel prossimo episodio speravi gli
sia piaciuto ragazzi cosi e mi piace
anche persone di tutta la sezione se
questa si chiede e noi come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video della
ragazza
[Musica]